I was just so I'm just so tired I didn't
home till 1:30 last night what are you
doing hey just watch it with Golden
Globes party where you are nothing award
show I watched three episodes of the Oh
a ha ha ha dude what was last night I
was I am this girl I met I wound up
meeting with the other night went out
with some friends uh-huh
and so I'm at the Comedy Cellar I sit
down with her and her girlfriends and
abundant another comedian so I'm talking
to them and I realize they all kind of
know each other I think they were all
there with this comic and then we're
playing these weird games like you pass
a piece of paper around and you do it we
use a slumber party trust me you draw
the head of something and then you fold
it down and you pass it over then you
draw the body and you each drawing on
the paper and at the end you look at
your funny drawings as I'm doing on the
weekends I know I I don't I'll tell you
how I got roped into this your quest to
be normal is like so funny to me I feel
like you do these things that you
wouldn't be doing if you were healthy no
here's what happened I saw a girl she
was a blonde girl and she was she had
big feet I want to talk to her so I was
talking to her so you drew so it was mad
libs we were scheduled I was like
pictionary but mad libs so we do that
for a while and then I fight I'm the guy
I'm like who you want tonight what time
to go online I forgot his name and he
was on a comic I didn't know him so I
basically just sat down with these four
stretchers trying to play [ __ ] the
equivalent of Madeleine right so there
was a little nervous torso this is crazy
I was he's got bare feet but he's
wearing a sweatshirt I was already alone
cold I don't understand so I lined up I
wind up going are a man let's get out of
here and then the one girl goes on
Saturday yeah she goes oh hey we're
going to my house do you want to come
and then she's like yeah and of and and
two other comedians are going to meet us
there so I got right I'll go back there
and this is not the blonde girls little
girl so I go back [ __ ] it I'm also am I
going to do I mean I was hanging out
with a friend but she was out so I'm
like I'll just go back so back to the
house and we watched two episodes she's
a weird girl we just watched two
episodes of this new TNT show about
TNT yeah it's talking about a network
that you do not hear about behavior or
bad behavior
TNT used to be the home for drama there
is nothing that is spoken about on TV
I'll tell you this is Nitro this is the
good behavior about the girl who's a con
artist and she gets caught up with this
hitman for hire it's not your own line
it's a thin plot it's a yes in fact so
does it doesn't start to run dry as the
episodes go yeah it started really good
it started great the first the pilot
episode starts really great you like
this is going to be a [ __ ] excellent
show and then of course like most shows
it just it's a girl yeah so I watched
two episodes with that she was sitting
next to me on the couch but there was
other people so I'm like maybe there's a
vibe here I couldn't tell this little
body contact nothing but then it was
time to go and everybody left how do you
know it's time to go because everybody
started getting up to leave and she was
like alright she turned the TV off was
at the end we were there for like three
hours I know but it's a bummer because
you'd be like oh if everybody's leave in
like you want to just hang out and watch
a movie or she made popcorn I was eating
popcorn she gave me I was just it was
just a childish night I really was just
eating popcorn watching TNT and then it
was just time to go well I got home very
late went to bed woke up did what I did
yesterday then she texts me oh and she
goes uh hey I'm having secluding around
about she said one time she has invited
some guy over who she thought she knew
but it turned out she knows from tinder
so he was a tinder day so he just showed
up at our house while she had a bunch of
friends over so she was pretty funny she
said she did that by Miss total mistake
running the guy walked over and thinking
is this tinder date we wanted to get the
other herd of friends it was just awful
she just liked to have friends over she
likes having friends over okay so she
invites me over she's having some I
think some girlfriend over - who's doing
she's doing her hair and she asked me if
I want to get like do I want to get a
mask or whatever don't like all right I
guess I'll do that Italy okay so how old
is this girl I don't know hey I don't
I'm gonna guess 26 ok 107 girl in your
20s you're hanging out with her this is
the first night you're with friends
you're watching three episodes Vantage
horrible TNT has a text message yeah and
you have to then you have to just leave
after that after you're done watching
the episodes you just go home it was
really late and I didn't mind going home
because they were actually really cool
people like this guy the guy who we were
having that lyrical I do not know trust
me I know it sounds actually I forgot
you were drawing pictures with them yeah
oh my god I think I was pretty funny and
he wasn't a comedian um but I'm almost
like they're just normal people I'm
hanging out with you really do not have
a celebrity aura about you and I really
don't know I just went to these people's
houses and program
and then she calls you the next day text
me text you and she goes you I'm getting
my hair done by my girlfriend I don't
know her Ben was coming over doing her
own hair her own hair her dying our own
hair and she was at first she telling me
how she's going on it was 14 year olds
did I know we're gonna try to dye our
hair with highlighters do you want to
come over she told me we're having some
she was some friends over and do I want
to come just hang now my kid why not
like get a mask she well she mentioned
but my friends doing her hair I do want
to do anything like get out like a
facial mask or like okay girl would do
that I wasn't doing anything I was okay
so I go over there just her and her
girlfriend and I asked her to I'm going
to bring anything so I'm a ship guest
and she's like some gummy bears would be
nice so I didn't want to eat bad so I go
across the street from my house I get a
giant salad for myself because I can
order pizza
I don't know Pizza I get a giant salad
for myself it's so cool to dressing I
don't behind I know I guess nobody told
me it was a bring your own salad party
put a salad or twenty something old girl
but you iov bring your own veggies
apparently so she gets me I bring my
salad I bring gummy bears I bring to our
X bars and I bring some [ __ ] I bring
some [ __ ] um some salted cashews yeah
I brought raw unsalted cashew our X bar
should not have been your only protein
short you haven't I
no I know I smacked so that I wanted to
have a healthy I don't you I don't you a
[ __ ] fat for a girl might even
[ __ ] write clubs she was gonna take
out she's young so I get there
and we're sitting there and she's like
um guess what
and I'm like what and she goes I invited
someone tonight I'm like who
and she's like a tinder date she invited
that in today
what are you doing so this really does
sound like you're visiting somebody in
their dorm room it says she invites a
kid I'm like why why how old are you by
the way I've been in my early 40s 49 in
your life and believe me that occurred
to me that occurred to me as I was
sitting there watching VOA so we're
watching the Oh Amy and her she crazy
this girl well she you know she had some
wine and she says to me
um I'm talking to her sick it'll be
funny and I'm like I'm like he's gonna
feel catfished and she's like no I'm
like I'm not pretending to be some of
her friends always [ __ ] her girlfriend
was encouraging her so I'm like I'm not
numbered do it
this guy's gonna hate it but when I
gonna do I mean would you think that was
fun if you were on tinder no I am on
tinder no I would so if some girl was
like you should come over to my place if
there was some other girl and a guy just
sitting there watching the oay no so she
just she didn't indicate that we were
there so since he's not going to show up
I'm like he's going to show up but she
sitting next to me on the couch right
like it so now there's no one on this
sofa and she's sitting next to me okay
which is nice like given like when
someone submission there's this little
arm contact nothing crazy but they don't
need to be this like wait I mean you
wouldn't watch TV right and maybe maybe
the tinder thing is like this little
mental connection like this is our
little inside joke she's trying to
create some intimacy but maybe you two
may possibly so she's not going to show
up like he's going to show up and I say
to her I'm like and then I like an hour
later she's here
I'm like all right ottoman and I'm like
he's going to feel catfished and when
that word bugged her she's like you
think so
I'm like yeah it's like it's a tender
thing he's gonna be very easy to feel
like he's being made a fool of she
probably watched the show on MTV I know
she's young yeah and then she felt
bashing I feel bad maybe he won't come
up I'm like he's gonna come up so she
writes to I say text him that we're all
here so she writes okay she texts him
that we're all here right and then
nothing happened
like I guess it spokes him he laughed um
no he didn't the doorbell right this guy
was a [ __ ] trooper so he walked in
he's not a bad-looking dude he's like
he's easily about 3334 he comes in and
he's like awkward immediately like me
and her on the couch her friend's doing
her hair and then he walks in he just
starts checking his phone he's like uh
like do you realize there's a
possibility where he knows who you are I
didn't I did think of that but since no
one else seems like why should this be
any different like so there wasn't this
feeling in the room of this guy has a
certain amount of celebrity to that name
it's kind of absurd to not just that
they did not know none of them I think
could care less which is fine so I'm
sitting there he gets out and he's
standing around and she's drinking wine
and then he just sits on a couch next to
us
um and it's her and me and him on the
couch and she's sitting next to me and
she's not sitting next to him and then
he's just drinking some wine we're
commenting on the occasion between you
two
she she's closer to me okay we're
commenting on the show which is not a
particularly it's a weird show I'll say
that so we're kind of goofing on it we
don't know exactly it's hard to call oh
I've heard good things about it I'm a
bad thing yeah it's a hard to follow
I hear you either like if you don't hear
the ending if you don't like it you're
really going to hate it
polarizing is what they're saying that's
a good word for Sam okay so we're
watching this for kind of talking about
it like what the [ __ ] going on we
didn't know and then he's like I'm like
this guy's guy he was not a bad dude
wasn't a dick right consider what he
walked into he's having wide and she's
talking and he's pretty
funny so he's okay and then he's um I
can't just want this guy to [ __ ]
leave comes trying to make out with this
girl cuz she is sitting close to me
right and would you go over there for
watch the oh and then he's like is
anybody hungry I'm like oh okay I was
but I might have a salad in your Rx they
were up on the [ __ ] thing obviously
you wanted to bring down your salad when
it was time for a mealtime but I didn't
want him staying no so then he's like
I'm gonna order some sushi and then I
and the girls think it's a great idea oh
the girls think it's a great idea to
order sushi so this guy orders sushi and
then like 40 minutes goes by is that
what it d-bag you're a young man yes do
you feel like I mean I know you got a
girlfriend but your honor have you done
tinder or anything like that before yeah
before so if you're on if I say this
same scenario pipes in is this the type
of thing that you would do like would
you or just be like oh I'm hungry like
to order food to somebody else's house
or I'd be out of there in 10 minutes you
would be I won't probably he probably
wanted to leave but again it was an
awkward thing to leave because there's
nothing bad happening so he was just
trying to because he didn't know the
score he could tell that she and I were
sitting close together but I don't think
he knew well it was another girl then
another girl he's trying to figure out
what's the what's the vibe here you know
yeah but he wasn't being an [ __ ] he
was kind of going with it and I liked
him I thought he was okay but after a
while I just started to get so [ __ ]
angry I'm like I'm 48 I'm watching the
Oh way which is what am i doing in this
[ __ ] right house right and yeah and
honestly like just to protect your own
self-esteem there are moves that you
have to make in life you know what I
mean like their time this is why you
come in at today's feeling worthless no
matter what you accomplish all of this
yet heard to me yes and I said to myself
I kind of like this girl I didn't know
if I like you're like if we had any real
chemistry but all these things if I hang
out someone two nights in a row I don't
have to [ __ ] them but I wanted to so I'm
like I'm just getting more and more
annoyed and her body contact was good we
were sitting together that stuff does
matter yes but and then all of a sudden
then she was sitting like not quite as
close so I'm like what am i [ __ ]
doing in this I'm like I'm already
thinking you could pick up on your
annoyance yeah yeah so staring straight
ahead
I like [ __ ] you in your oversized
my private pilot's out here on the
toilet that I wasn't on suckin so I
finally I saw I'm going the bathroom
again
so he goes he goes hey does anybody want
to order food you just give him the my
head still tilted down but my eyes are
looking up private Pyle stare yeah hi
Joker no I didn't want food so they
don't eat new sushi and the other girl
was fine she was dying she was dyeing
her hair she was cool so I'm like I put
my shoes on yeah and I go to the
bathroom and I don't even come back to
the couch I get my jacket I'm like a I'm
gonna take off my cigar so I'm so angry
she's even gonna have to hug me she's go
see you later like you're one of the
guys yep so I wind up getting how'd you
get friend-zoned and like I know I wind
up getting my rx bars it's not gonna
leave them behind and my thumb and my
omelets and my almonds and I put them in
my pocket and I leave I left my Sally
hahaha
so I'm in such a [ __ ] so angry
wearable you hi guys I go outside and I
get into the cab and the guy's like
how's your night and I'm like awful and
I go home and it's like Oh what time is
it I'll tell you in a second what time
this is if I want to dye her hair go
hold on and it's like you haven't
watched the Golden Globes
I don't need I've forgot they were on
you didn't get to sleep early for the
show like as well yes d-bag did you have
a question yes this was after all this
one yes good whatever happened with the
facial mask it never happened it's a
great question it never happened we
didn't get so I was so annoyed are we
doing the mask or not so I wind up it's
I get a text in the cab okay sorry for
the awkwardness should never have
actually invited tinder guy okay so I
write back
you know they look I just don't have
enough time socially
do that like to [ __ ] around like I wanna
hear oh yeah I'm like I wasn't man like
if I wanted if I'm like I wanted to hang
with you and you and your friends I'm
okay with me I was like let her know it
didn't have to be a [ __ ] party I'm like
but look at the bright side I left now
it's not awkward so I'm like okay
whatever did you say that literally it
didn't have to be a [ __ ] party but I
know I didn't guess I think she
understood question why when I walked
out like close the door the door didn't
close it just bounced like you know how
it doesn't close all the way and you
don't pull it I kind of left the door
open and I'm like yeah [ __ ] that I ain't
closing this just high school Jimi's
through siding up it's funny exactly
what it is you're walking out you're
just like this is one of those I'm an
awful but I don't want to here's why I
want to leave at first I stop with this
guy for like two hours a part of me was
like I'm not going to get alpha male by
some strange guy and just leave the
situation but secondly it was like I
work in the morning right I have a job
to do your pride starts kicking it and
but I'm also like why am I sitting here
the first part wasn't for the first hour
I'm like look the reality is this I
don't know who this guy is and yes she
did something stupid but when you're in
that situation and you're leaving
someone in the apartment of the strange
guy there is that weird like I know she
brought on herself she did it but
there's a thing as a male like you're
like is this guy a [ __ ] am i walking
out of something bad gonna happen but
after like 2 or 3 hours he was fine I
could tell he was not a [ __ ] who
knows he did he seemed okay
right but even after that point I was
like I didn't care I was like I'm
leaving you wanted to go into protector
mode not protectable but you just don't
want to leave and have something
horrible happen ago that was avoidable
realizing that uh literally anybody that
knows who you are would think exactly
that about finding out the Jim Norton
was in the apartment yeah yeah well I
know yeah Jim Norton in the apartment
but who was this other guy so it was it
was highschool Jimmy I left I didn't
even read you know the wait is that like
mentally did that happen no matter what
we accomplish in our lives that all it
takes is one action of one girl who
means nothing to you to bring you right
back to the dude in high school that
wasn't getting laid
well if it brings if it if it validates
what you already think yes if it doesn't
then fine but validates what you already
think about yourself
yes so I walked out I wouldn't say I was
sad I was more angry like you [ __ ]
annoying [ __ ] like I was even I was more
like myself for going over right I was
even that mad at her because she and I
didn't have any romantic connection she
was kind of doing it all to be a goof
but all she'd one day she was just a
weirdo that was like yeah over to my
house yeah she wasn't being horrible so
she writes me you know I said I kinda
wanted to hang with you were you and
your friends and she writes back I feel
bad likewise she says should I come to
yours I think they're leaving for
sapphires she thinks this guy and her
friend were leaving for a strip club so
I am Cairo well do you want to and she
writes back IOU
so what that would be funny but actually
that was pretty douchey move yeah I do
it's frozen out though where are you so
I was already back up in my apartment
because she lives pretty close but I'm
like whoa I'm still outside
I said I'm hopping a cab I hopped in a
cab no you told her you were outside her
building no liability no no no I told
you we're not all right no I was always
like just walking she to go back
downstairs get a cab and come back to
her place yeah okay so I said I wrote my
salad is still there when are they
leaving and she wrote they just left so
this by the way let me ask you something
did you leave that salad there no like
you know I no no no girl will leave her
gloves eat always and be like oh I do
have to come back like when I first
started dating Jess her ex-boyfriend
lived like way up in Connecticut and
when I was first like kind of like
kicking it to her a little bit the guy
she was like oh my ex is coming back
because he said I left CDs in his car
and I was like what so I knew what was
going on you don't drive all the way
back from Connecticut to give her CDs
and then he gets there and forgot the
CDs of course so I was like so that is
obviously a deliberate move people do it
all the time didn't you don't think
somewhere in your subconscious you left
the salad purposely at the Oh a girl
town no I tell you why I Dobbs
completely opposite by the way Ashley
Butterfield on Twitter just tweeted a
photo of them face hanging out with CV
Rachel and Ross and all the other
friends chef Alissa Jeff actually ship
hanging out on the couch with the crew
from know I actually one of the reasons
I stayed was because I knew this would
be funny to talk about on the radio I
did occur to me I got to talk about this
on the air at all especially because it
is like the greatest juxtaposition next
to Adrienne's mary jean story if like
yeah just text her and she came over and
she [ __ ] my brains out and shoved her
hand up my ass exactly but on the way
out i'm thinking of myself this is why i
spend the money I spent like this is why
I like as I'm going down the oven I'm
like people wonder why I live this
lightly oh you're crazier detached from
humanity but this is why right this is
what you deal with so I get there and I
did I I actually didn't leave my salad
it would have been funny I was too
humiliating
to take my salad in a shopping bag and
walk out of it and walked out is why
that was why and I'm taking my salad
with me exactly that's my advice for any
of you that's why I left my salad I see
so I came back he looked at it when I'm
gonna leave I'm gonna leave the salad
behind it'd be too [ __ ] weird to walk
out of the door with holding the
shopping bag that was widened so I come
back and this guy's already gone with
this other good by the way
whoever this guy is yeah what a
professional yeah you know forever you
this guy's a professional [ __ ]
operator he walked into a weird
situation
two girls again I he not only took him
to Jessie has a glass and I have two
glasses of wine he's kind of being funny
watching the show not a bad dude he
ordered sushi for everyone he's not a
dick he could've been a total dick I
leave he doesn't even stay I was almost
like I don't even care if she [ __ ] he
doesn't even stay in trying to [ __ ] a
girl he takes the other girl to a strip
club that's what I hope he got laid this
guy's great for all of her for your
theory of this is why I pay people
because I wanted to deal with the hassle
you have guys that understand that
without paying for anybody they're able
to answer a tender date show up wait
till the cup leaves the room and then
take the girlfriend and head to a strip
maybe but there's a lot of work involved
with that and there's also he's sitting
there drinking with them he probably has
to go out and hang for a couple hours in
the club does he get laid who knows and
by that time
four o'clock in the morning I do radio I
think I do I'm a little limited only
part of it is hard to cut out the
[ __ ] you have to do yeah you know
there's a lot of nighttime like people
don't work nothing works you like it two
hours we're done that it's a long time
dude not even two hours if you pay
really have a massage river or set it's
an hour an hour um I don't mind hanging
with somebody but in order to work for
it this guy might have been also four
o'clock in the morning and maybe didn't
write because the night before that when
I was hanging out with all those girls
if I didn't get anything just right on
the cheek goodbye but it was a fun hang
I didn't care to do was there who lives
in her building it was silly it was fly
to give a [ __ ] it was so weird it was
fun though but it was there were nice
people I don't home and watch the crown
which is a masterpiece right so I
[ __ ] uh I go back to her house this
guy's gone she's very nice and she's
apologetic she's like look like she's
actually a cool girl she's like I
thought that'd be really funny but it
was kind of a dick move I shouldn't have
done that
and so we just go upstairs and the
[ __ ] show is still on I'm on outside
every go kind and then we just sat there
made out for a little while okay so
all's well that ends well all's well
that ends well but that was as far as I
got
and then she's like she's really she's
actually really funny and she has a good
sense of humor so she was very fun to
hang with but she doesn't have to get up
in the morning for work right and she
was bummed that I had to leave I'm like
yeah I gotta leave I can't get I gotta
get up you think he could have done more
than make out if he didn't have to leave
it's uh it wasn't said but I it's
possible but I don't know I won't i
won't say definitely asks i don't always
assume that stuff but i had to leave and
say Co you do I stayed for like an extra
40 minutes and came home like I left at
1:00 I'm like you know I'm like ah go
home and be home in bed by like month or
whatever was see on the way in the cab
home my big dinner was to our x-bars I
left his salad once again she was known
as I'm coming back he felt so bad she's
like do you want your salad in the bowl
I don't want to put on a plate for you I
thought the fact she was gonna feed me
my own salad but I'm like no I saw what
I'm eating 2rx bars in the cab and I
went home I went right to bed like a
good boy and slept for a couple hours
that's very good look at you you're kind
of living like a college kid you know it
was it was weird this is fun fun Jim it
was a Nandi
TV at night so I didn't I didn't feel
bad about that like it seems like a non
deviant weekend and I totally get
nothing how do we get non deviant